[Musique]
harry potter est une unité secrète elle
a été créée pour renforcer la puissance
de notre armée
ces éléments sont partie de l'élite vous
ferez face aux missions les plus
dangereuses et aux défis les plus
improbables y compris la mort
c'est une guerre devait éclater demain
est ce que vous seriez prêt à le faire
celui qu'ils appellent le prêtre dont
ils ont demandé la libération et le chef
de l'organisation faisceau lumineux
il responsable de nombreuses attaques
terroristes
frappât tv
trois peuples pourraient vraiment
souffrir si on n'accepte pas de se
battre pour lui j'effectuerai cette
mission
n'oubliez jamais
voudra que qu'il ne faut pas tomber
entre leurs mains
qui fait complet par la noirceur ne
verront jamais la vraie lumière
couvrez pas
chaque seconde passée au sol est une
perte de temps précieux